we have a voicemail number that number
is 219 to David P here is a furious
trumpist caller who sounds like she
really wants to speak to the manager
um who do you think you are you know you
pop this ass uh calling Mega people
mentally ill you know that's a real
stretch you know you gotta get off this
stuff
who Do You Think You Are
nobody
so again listen uh I have never said
all Maga people are mentally ill
but I've interviewed enough of them and
our correspondents have interviewed
enough of them to know
that some of these Maga people are
mentally ill and the manifestation is an
obsession with Trump and Trump
paraphernalia and Trump gear others just
are ignorant about politics others are
selfish and greedy and they identified
that Trump policies would be good for
them you know it's a combination who am
I I'm just like you I you have an
opinion and I have an opinion and we
express the opinions it just might be
that more people are listening to my
opinion than yours but who am I I'm just
a guy that's it we have a great voice
bonus show for you today has the world
made progress on climate change like all
of the years now of rallies and marches
and Provisions and agreements have we
made what we can call progress on
climate change we will discuss based on
a new report
secondly New Zealand is going to vote on
whether to lower the voting age to 16.
what do we think of it I will tell you
and we will talk about the rising cost
of Thanksgiving and I will again
advocate for ditching the turkey and
doing two or three beautiful
chickens potentially spatchcocked I know
I know I will address that on the bonus
show sign up at joinpakman.com don't
miss it coupon code 24 starts now gets
you a discount
I love cooking at home I cook all the
time having a good set of knives that
you actually like to use is really
important for years I have been a fan of
the advantages that Japanese knives
offer and our sponsor kamikodo makes
amazing Japanese steel kitchen knives
using the traditional techniques that
date back to the Edo period of Japan
kamikoto only uses steel from Japan each
blade takes years to craft and goes
through a rigorous 19-step inspection
process with a lifetime guarantee the
knives come in a beautiful heavy duty
Ash wood box makes it a really great
gift easy to store as well on the
kamikota website you can see a map of
the Michelin star chefs all over the
world using kamikoto knives my kamikoto
knives at home have been performing
great for years you really just can't
beat the feel of a nice Japanese knife
perfectly balanced in your hand and
kamikoto is now running a big Black
Friday sale my audience gets an extra
fifty dollars off go to kamikodo.com
Pacman and use the code Pacman the link
is down below